what's up so I recent got a question for
one of my loyal YouTube and Twitter
followers Peter who wrote in to say
what's up I've never done a what's up
video so not really quite sure how to
lead it off I guess I'll start with the
business side I'm going all in on
youtube i'm spending so much of my time
making videos and trying to make them a
lot better last month was was the best
month ever for the channel had almost
500,000 views and record number of
subscribers I'm part of a talent agency
and last month I had the largest growth
in new subscribers on YouTube than
anybody at the agency so I'm super
excited and pumped about that i've also
been playing around with the YouTube
schedule and taking out some of the
videos that weren't doing as well and
adding a lot more questions and a lot
more things in that I feel passionate
about right now with the YouTube channel
I'm exploring the lighting and the
background this is a new layout that
I've got going on now I'm thinking maybe
I should be doing it outside i'm
thinking i might have light boxes i'm
playing with it I feel like the
background is a little boring here so
I'm open to suggestions I don't want it
to look cluttered but I wanted to be a
little more inspiring so if you have
seen great videos with great backgrounds
leave it in the comments below or if you
have suggestions for me let me know
because that's what I'm struggling with
right now also in the business side I am
working on my book deal I have a couple
calls with publishers next week which
should be exciting I've started an
online mastermind group where I'm
coaching entrepreneurs every Monday
morning and getting them set up and
primed and ready for success for the
week that's been very rewarding and a
lot of fun and I'm working on a secret
ninja project that I'm super excited
about it could be really game-changing
that I'm not ready to release yet but
fingers crossed hopefully it'll be
coming soon on the personal side I just
came back from Disney World there's been
a bunch of videos that we've put up that
you can check out I took my Vespa out
for the first right of the season which
is super excited I love being on my
Vespa I had the
away my vibram five toe shoes after I
don't know how many years I've had them
but I wore through them a Disney World
and I was sad about it and sorry gotta
go get myself a new pair and we're
probably going to start a garden soon I
know Nina is a huge gardening Fame and
is gonna want to start one and I'm going
to be dragged into it and they're part
of your video into coming out about it
so that's what's up with me I want to
know what's up with you give me a quick
update how things are going in your
business and in your life leave a
comment and who knows maybe this will
become a regular series I don't know
leave a comment below let me know what's
up and if you liked this video you want
to see more don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and the newsletter thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon